j'ai vu le matin
un drame inattendu
pierre flynn votre chanson la maudite
machine va bientôt célébrer ses 50 ans
elle va être intronisé au panthéon des
auteurs et compositeurs canadiens le 6
mars prochain à l'émission belle et bum
magnifique chanson qui commence avec
cette scène avec des itinéraires
d'où vous est venu le flash l'idée de
base les flèches de départ l'ofc pas
tout on sortait pour aller prendre une
bière même sillage l'âge pour aller
prendre bientôt de 21 ans et on avait 16
17 ans c'était le vieux montréal
alors on sortait du métro et là il y
avait un escalier qui venait à la place
vauquelin puis à la terre promise c'est
à dire le la plage à claques et dans les
grandes soirées ou dans les fêtes
nationales il y avait toujours au pied
de cet escalier lors des itinérants les
itinérants sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes que ceux de jours juste souvent
les lieux et monsieur de larges l'eau
par les vétérans de la guerre souvent et
c'est de voir ce qui a été le déclic que
la clé
qui ment fait sortir ses premières
images j'ai vu un matin un vieux robin
m'a tendu la main pour une scène deux
spas drôle dans la rue donc
effectivement j'étais un petit cul qui
connaissait absolument rien pas
grand-chose la ville centre qui vivait
chez ses parents évidemment et qui
découvrait que ben
l'injustice et la misère faisait partie
de notre monde
soit 12
[Musique]
où vous êtes réunis à quelques reprises
octobre je pense la dernière fois
c'était avec karkwa au métropolis très
bon spectacle à chaque fois que vous
retrouvez ce que vous étiez des amis
d'enfance
ça va être ma j'ai passé c'est magique
c'est la magie de la vieille pente au
foot et mêmes vieilles pantoufles
c'est magique non c'est confortable tu
retrouves les mêmes la même dynamique
les mêmes petites et patience et outils
mais je pense à d'autres bandes où il ya
eu des gros chicane et je nous considère
chanceux d'avoir pu éviter ça
[Musique]
en solo vous avez écrit le magnifique
chanson on a parlé sur la route mais en
et là dessus un petit bijou que c'est
sur la chanson le dernier homme
on dirait que c'est une chanson qui a
été écrite pour la pandémie parce
qu'aujourd'hui
ben oui vous chantez cette étrange je me
sens comme le dernier homme comme s'il
n'y avait plus personne
comme ce qu'il avait oublié que j'ai
jamais passé à ce rapprochement que vous
faites mais a posteriori
ça a du bon sens des fois ce qu'on a
écrit dans le passé
les chansons sont comme des petits êtres
vivants ou alors ils sont bien morts qui
sont cachés dans garde-robe ou alors ils
vivotent puis se transforme qui changent
de couleur avec les années puis ils
prennent des résonances à par rapport à
l'air du temps par rapport aux
événements puissent pense je pense que
ce dont vous parlez est peut-être pas un
pressentiment moi je pensais plutôt un
scénario de science-fiction comme
personne
mais il attendait toujours dix ans à
voir sortir du nouveau matériel
ah non mais c'est vrai je peux vous
mettre de pression mais pourquoi une si
longue attente c'est pas comme si vous
avez eu un gros échec artistique je
pense ce qui est ce qui est un sofa ici
je pourrais m'étendre sur sophocle
pourriez me faire une idée rapide
peut-être qu'on en saura plus lors là
dessus ggd déplorable habitude de
travail je suis pas ma méthode n'est pas
la bonne
j'ai fait beaucoup de coaching auprès
des auteurs compositeurs je leur dis
toujours de grâce faites pas comme moi
fait des exercices fait des ateliers
participer à des causes que j'ai jamais
fait je sais pas trop quoi quoi vous
répondre là dessus
tout ce que je sais c'est que pour moi
écrire quelque chose qui a une vraie
vibrations de dallas quelque chose qui
ne fait pas de doute dans mon esprit et
dans mon corps et ça n'arrive pas tous
les jours puis
je me pose toujours la question là
présentement je me pose la question est
ce que j'ai encore quelque chose à dire
est ce que parce que c'est fini mon
affaire je pense paul g j'ai de plus en
plus le goût d'aller voir pierre flynn
merci beaucoup merci à vous gens seuls
[Musique]